[Music]
beginning in the 1950s women serving in
the u.s military could face
immediate discharge not for any
misconduct
but because they've become pregnant or
had recently given birth
that policy changed in the 1970s but
it's only in recent years that pregnant
women and young mothers
have been welcomed and accommodated in
america's armed forces
natalie brand has the story air force
major lauren daly landed a dream job on
an aircraft that flies top
government officials our top five
is our primary customer and why we exist
so that's the
first lady the vice president the
chairman of the joint chiefs the
secretary of defense and the secretary
of state
but at home she has a different title
mom
juggling life with newborn hope and
toddler jacob
when i first got into the military 10
years ago there were not a lot of
females
in the higher ranks and the ones that
were did not have children or did not
choose to have a family
to make it to where they were and now
you're kind of starting to see
like more women in the wing commander
positions and squadron commander
who have done it that's helping to shape
new policies like
one enacted in 2019 requiring nursing
mothers have access to private and
sanitary lactation
areas policy sets cultures so that's a
significant win for us
i think change takes time it's not going
to happen
overnight but i'm very optimistic it's
progress that was not in place when
lieutenant colonel jessica ruttenberg
was pregnant with her first child
nine years ago my conversations went
away from
would you like to take this more
competitive job that is more demanding
to accelerate your career
to would you like to separate at the end
of your service commitment or take this
less demanding job to become more with
your children which would have been fine
they didn't ask my husband the same
question and that's when i started
realizing
that motherhood sometimes had a little
bit of a barrier
in the institution the mother of three
who is married to a fellow air force
pilot says the military
is taking steps to combat pregnancy bias
including this memo from former defense
secretary mark
esper last year which said the
department will
update its military equal opportunity
policy to prohibit
pregnancy-based discrimination i am
setting
12 weeks of fully paid maternity leave
as the standard across the joint force
another key change increased maternity
leave
and a one-year deferment from deployment
and physical fitness testing in the air
force
a new bill proposes to expand that to
all military branches and
increase leave to 12 weeks for both
parents
the war department was designed for sort
of a 1950s model
right for a male and a stay-at-home wife
and that has changed now so we're still
working through those changes but every
day it is getting better i don't want to
worry major aliyah nadim
chairs the air force women's initiative
team are you allowed to reveal your
secret motto
yes our secret motto is get stuff done
and i am super proud of that because we
don't just talk about it we actually do
it
the dress and appearance instruction
like getting hair style standards
eased for years service women said
having to wear their hair in these tight
buns
caused headaches and hair loss now
ponytails or
braids are allowed or the development of
a maternity flight suit just last year
these might seem like small changes but
major nadim says
all together they will make the military
stronger
we know women at the 10-year mark get
out at higher rates than their male
peers
why is that and we did some research and
one of them is
family planning lack of access to child
care
it's been a slow climb to the top
leadership levels
retired general ann dunwoody became the
military's first
four star female military officer in
2008
the list of four star females in
military history
is only seven long so far each of these
women have led careers demonstrating
incomparable skill integrity and
duty to country and at every step
they've also helped push open the doors
of opportunity
to women in our military this past march
president joe biden named two female
generals to prestigious four-star
commands
if confirmed they would be just the
second and third women to lead combatant
commands
why do you think it matters to have not
only women in the military
but moms in the military well i think
that it's a retention so if you want to
keep women in the military for
a full career cycle 20 years you're
going to have to accept that they're
going to want to have children
at some point most of them are the
second reason is i think it's essential
for our national security to
have a more inclusive military i think
it makes us more lethal
service members like lieutenant colonel
ruttenberg and major daly are rising the
ranks
and realizing motherhood has not
grounded their careers but rather has
made them better leaders
so now people my age and younger are
kind of seeing like maybe i can do both
i don't have to make a choice
and get out when my commitment's over
when i want to start having a family
it's possible yes it is for cbs
this morning saturday natalie brand
washington
breaking down those barriers to access
is the key and they seem like they're
doing it
and there we say this so much but you
really do have to see it sometimes
yeah to think that that's what you want
to do know that you can be a mom
and have a career in the military and
those small changes are huge
yeah yeah thanks to natalie for that
yeah